good morning believe nation today's
message is you have to diversify over to
you Kevin O'Leary
diversification but I've learned that
works if you're an investor no matter
how much money you've got whether it's
five thousand dollars or 500 million
diversification is what saves you from
disaster having investments in a wide
range of businesses and sectors there's
always something working when something
else isn't so today I can go to bed
tonight knowing that I have one
objective I want to go to bed richer
than I woke up and the only way that's
gonna happen to me is to be invested in
a lot of different things because every
day one thing works well three others
don't but sometimes that's why you get
richer this is the first in spresso that
I've had a hard time with and I'm
wondering if I actually agree with it or
not I get how it works when you're
investing in stocks you don't want to
have more than 5% of your money into one
stock because if something happens and
you could lose a lot of your money but
I'm not sure that applies to the rest of
your life and any idea right he said
don't invest more than 5% in any idea
and I think as I'm as an entrepreneur
it's easy to spread yourself too thin
Lee and you should go all-in on the idea
that you love most if you only invest 5%
of your time or money into an idea that
means you're running at least 20
different ideas at the same time that's
crazy to me that that sounds like a
disaster waiting to happen and again
spreading yourself so thinly that you
can't get anything done instead you're
doing a lot of stuff in a mediocre way
instead of one thing really really
really well I'm a big believer in
betting on your strengths and when you
find it and that thing that you love and
you're passionate about it you go all-in
on it and I'm a fan of Andrew Carnegie
who became the richest man in the world
and he said an opposite of
diversification
he said put all your eggs in one basket
and then watch that basket so we've got
a couple different views on this one one
says diversify like crazy one says go
all-in on one thing I'm really curious
to find out what you guys think so
that's my question of the day for you
how much do you believe in
diversification for your business
leaving the comments below
I'm really
to find out thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day p'tee to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events presto